欢迎来到新的一期FP101x
今天讲的是递归函数（recursive function）
什么是递归
这有一堆托盘 还有我最喜欢的水果 现在你们知道我喜欢香蕉了
我要吃这些香蕉 如果用递归的方式来的话
首先要吃第一根香蕉 哦
在那之前 我必须先吃下一根香蕉
哦 我先把这根香蕉
放在这个托盘上 接下来我要吃
下一根香蕉 哎呀要吃这么多香蕉
这一堆栈（stack）越来越大 再下一根香蕉
到了最后一根香蕉了
把它放到堆里 看这一堆香蕉多漂亮
注意这种做法的问题在于
我们建立了一个大的香蕉堆栈
如果香蕉太多的话 就会栈溢出（overflow）
一种更好的方法是不要等下一根吃完了才开始吃第一根
这样只需要一个托盘就可以吃完所有的香蕉了
这叫做尾调用消除（tail call elimination）
尾调用消除是使用递归时的一个重要的定义控制结构的概念
过程式语言中通常没有尾调用消除
因此需要特殊的控制结构
但在 Haskell 中 我们可以安全地使用递归来定义控制结构
因为不会产生这么大一堆没吃的香蕉
很好 让我们看点代码吧
我觉得这些香蕉够吃一年了
Haskell 程序员喜欢递归 是因为它是一种很自然的定义函数的方式
例如要定义阶乘（factorial）函数 之前也见过
取 1 到 n 之间值的列表
再把它们乘到一起
比如求值 4 的阶乘 把定义展开
也就是 1 到 4 的乘积 这是 1 到 4 的列表 也就是 [1,2,3,4] 的乘积
最终的积就是把这些数都乘起来
[1, 2, 3, 4] 的乘积 就是 1*2*3*4 也就是 24
下面是用递归的方式定义阶乘
我们已经看过如何定义列表的递归函数
取列表 检查是否为空表
还是一个头元素（head）接一个尾列表（tail）
某种程度上 数字上的递归函数也是一样
要考虑两种情况 一是当数字为 0 时
另一种情况是数字为 n
在第二种情况下 就在 n-1 上进行递归
之前版本的 Haskell 中有一种叫做 n+k 的模式
你可以定义为 0 时的阶乘 还有 n+1 时的阶乘
但 n+k 模式已经弃置不用了
现在只能用这种形式写了
但除了这个小细节之外 可以看出和在列表上的递归很像
两种情况 0 和 n 等于 0 的时候结果是 1
否则先取 n-1 的阶乘 再乘上 n
如果对这种形式的阶乘求值 就会发现堆栈 变得像香蕉一样
这是因为阶乘会首先不断进入右边的调用 等一切都执行完
再乘回来
从栈中弹出 得到结果 6
好了
我们给出的阶乘递归定义
可能会停不下来 用术语来说就是 对小于 0 的数字发散（diverge）
让我们回去看看
如果 n 小于 0
那么不符合这种情况 因此将 n 与 n-1 的阶乘相乘
参数比 0 更小了 依此类推 永远不会停下
最终会造成栈溢出
像阶乘这样的有些函数 可以递归定义 或用其他函数定义
无论是用递归方式定义
还是使用其他函数定义
又或者把递归的模式抽象成高阶函数（higher-order function）
再用它来定义 其实只是品味问题
最终 作为一个开发者要决定的是 怎样最方便其他开发者阅读 对吧
因此是否要用递归这个问题 没有一个明确的答案
代码越简洁越好
但使用递归的一个好处是
可以递推（induction）证明程序的性质
让我们再看一个递归定义函数的例子
之前定义阶乘时用到的乘积（product）函数
让我们用列表上的递归来定义 这样结构完全相同
有两种情况要考虑 要么是空列表
要么是 n 连接着（cons） ns
对照着列表的递归结构
再将函数定义在递归的结构上
这和数字是一样的 首先对照数字的递归结构
再根据那种结构定义函数
回到这里 如果要计算空表的乘积
结果就是 1
如果要对元素 n 和列表 ns 计算乘积
该怎么做 首先取余下列表的乘积 再乘上 n
因此这是个很简单的用递归定义函数的方式
当然 我们也可以取这个函数
将其模式抽象成一个高阶函数 只处理递归
然后可以放入乘法和 1 就行
如果执行乘积函数 展开列表定义 2 连接 3 和 4
再展开乘积的定义
得到 2 乘上 [3, 4] 的乘积 如此反复几次
直到这一步
最后从栈中弹出 得到结果 24
可以看到答案和阶乘的递归定义完全相同
唯一的区别就是 这里的递归隐藏在乘积函数里
如果计算 1 到 n 的乘积 事实上是在用递归定义函数
并且可以说明
把两个函数合并到一起时 一个创建从 1 到 n 的列表 另一个是乘积函数 得到的和阶乘的递归定义一样
再看一个可以递归定义在列表上的函数
可以再次看到递归结构
如果列表是空的 空列表的长度是 0
如果表不是空的
我们不关心第一个元素具体是什么 直接计算其余列表的长度
再加上 1 就好了 十分明显
同样可以看到 它遵循了列表递归的结构
因此基本上是按列表结构递推定义的
计算 [1, 2, 3] 的长度
也就是 1 + [2, 3] 的长度 展开 展开 再展开
直到这里 再把它们加到一起
就得到了预期的结果 3
再看另一个函数反转列表（reverse）
对空列表来说 反转得到的还是空列表
如果想要反转 (x:xs)
只需要把 x 放到另外一边就行
如果像这样执行
可以看到元素变成了从右向左连接的
因此列表反转了
[1, 2, 3] 变成了 [3, 2, 1]
当然也可以定义不只在一个参数上递归 而是在多个参数上递归的函数
上一章介绍过 zip （拉链）函数
如何定义 zip 呢 zip 接收两个列表
它取两个列表中的元素 将它们结合成一对
最简单的情况是最后一种 如果有两个非空列表
取两个的头元素（head） 结合成一对
再递归地 zip 剩下的列表 什么时候停下呢
两个列表中只要有一个空了 就停下了
此时返回空表
当然我们需要把这两种情况放在前面 因为有个通配符（wild card）模式
否则就不对了
很好
再看几个函数
drop（丢弃）接收一个整数和一个列表
最终返回一个列表 它既在数字上递归 又在列表上递归
如果想从列表中丢弃 0 个元素
结果和原列表一样
当列表为空时
那丢弃多少元素都可以 只不过没什么作用 因此直接返回空列表
最后同时在列表和数字上递归
同样 因为没有 n+k 模式 右手边要用 n-1
因此从无论什么元素连接 xs  的列表中丢弃 n 个元素 得到的就是从 xs 中丢弃 n-1 个元素
因此这里既在数字上递归 又在列表的结构上递归了
课件上的最后一个例子是接续（append）两个列表
如果把一个空表接到另一个表上 结果和原来那个列表一样
如果想将 (x:xs) 的列表接到 ys 这个列表上时 首先将 xs 和 ys 接续到一起
再在前面连接（cons） x 十分显而易见
非常感谢 第二部分再见